Shure:  保持升级啊
Shure: Keep leveling up.
Shure:  这个来冲
Shure: Let's charge this.
Shure:  OK找到了
Shure: OK, found it.
Shure:  来吧无敌了我已经
Shure: Alright, I'm invincible now.
Shure:  能不能进来你们俩
Shure: Can you two come in?
Shure:  我弹半天
Shure: I've been playing for a while.
Shure:  这样摁的很很很累的你知道吗
Shure: It's really tiring to press like this, you know?
Nicous:  这个你要你弹到这个小节的时候
Nicous: When you play to this measure,
Shure:  你我我就直接从这进
Shure: I'll just come in right from there.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright?
Shure:  哇哇
Shure: Wow, wow.
Nicous:  我草吗哈哈哈哈哈哈对
Nicous: Damn, haha, yeah.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure:  我记不住了
Shure: I can't remember.
Shure: 啊A完了时候OA
Shure: Uh, when A is finished, then OA.
Shure:  哦哦哇哦哦
Shure: Oh oh wow oh oh.
Shure:  啊来三二一走
Shure: Okay, three, two, one, go.
Shure:  应该是回来拉吧
Shure: It should be coming back, right?
Shure:  对你看
Shure: Yes, see?
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Shure:  差不多不用太懂
Shure: Almost, you don't need to understand it too well.
Shure:  懂就不好了
Shure: Understanding it is not good.
Shure:  不纯粹了
Shure: It becomes less pure.
Shure:  相爱的方式
Shure: The way of loving.
Shure:  是不是跟下来的这边
Shure: Shouldn't it be over here?
Shure: 草
Shure: Damn.
Shure:  再来两遍我的手就就无敌了
Shure: If we do it two more times, my hands will be invincible.
Shure:  全部会了
Shure: I'll know it all.
Shure: 叫什么男人不能够说自已不行
Shure: What's that saying, men can't admit they can't do it.
Shure: 刚刚好在
Shure: Just in time.
Shure:  好在刚刚那句话没录进去
Shure: Good thing that last sentence wasn't recorded.
Shure:  来吧我尽量好吧
Shure: Come on, I'll do my best, okay?
Shure:  就我 我已经
Shure: I'm, I'm already...
Shure:  那好好从来
Shure: Alright, let's start over.
Shure:  哦后面换和弦
Shure: Oh, change the chord later.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 到是真没想到成功的话
Katrina: I really didn't expect it to succeed.
Katrina: 一直是报着失败的决心去
Katrina: I was always prepared for failure.
Katrina: 好神奇啊人生
Katrina: Life is so amazing.
Shure:  啦
Shure: La.
Shure:  就像我就知道
Shure: Like I already knew.
Shure:  我这段恋爱
Shure: This relationship of mine.
Shure:  好像就是没有什么任何结果
Shure: It seems like it won't have any result.
Shure:  就基本不可能有结果
Shure: It's basically impossible to have a result.
Shure:  但是我还是谈了一下
Shure: But I still went for it.
Katrina: 啊你现在这个啊为什么没结果
Katrina: Ah, this one now? Why won't it work out?
Shure:  我
Shure: I...
Katrina: 你要回家
Katrina: You have to go home.
Shure:  对我马上回家他出国
Shure: Yes, I'm going home soon and he's going abroad.
Shure:  英国
Shure: To the UK.
Shure:  我都能
Shure: I can still...
Shure:  还好其实
Shure: Actually, it's okay.
Shure:  但是
Shure: But
Shure:  他这两天就会感觉比比比比原来黏我
Shure: He feels more clingy these past two days compared to before.
Katrina:  感情果然会
Katrina: Feelings really do...
Shure:  大家都已经录完一遍了
Shure: Everyone has already recorded once.
Nicous: 我唱一首
Nicous: I'll sing one.
Nicous: 打开我的歌单
Nicous: Open my playlist.
Nicous:  我爱你
Nicous: I love you.
Shure:  我爱你是哪个
Shure: Which "I love you" is that?
Katrina: 就我们前两天放的那个
Katrina: The one we played a couple of days ago.
Nicous: 不那个也行那个
Nicous: No, that one works too.
Nicous: 或者那个
Nicous: Or that one.
Katrina: 这好试合你唱
Katrina: This one suits you better.
Shure: 一定要夹那个鼻音唱
Shure: You have to sing it with a nasal tone.
Nicous: 那个女孩那个女孩
Nicous: That girl, that girl.
Katrina: 那个女孩是不是陶喆
Katrina: Is "That girl" by David Tao?
Shure:  好像就是这两个人
Shure: It seems like it's by those two.
Shure:  我不知道啊
Shure: I don't know.
Shure:  他就是应该是大概这个感觉
Shure: It's supposed to be roughly like this.
Shure:  那个女孩是啥呀
Shure: What's "That girl"?
Nicous:  没听过吗
Nicous: Haven't you heard it?
Shure:  你们俩能不能点首
Shure: Can you two pick a song?
Shure:  最起码能唱出来的
Shure: At least one that can be sung properly.
Shure:  这个才对
Shure: This is the right one.
Shure:  词不对都都没发现吗
Shure: Didn't you notice the lyrics were wrong?
Shure:  你们两个
Shure: You two.
Shure:  couple four okay
Shure: Couple four, okay.
Shure:  来吧来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on, come on.
Nicous: 来这我能弹啊
Nicous: Let me try to play it.
Nicous:  弹不了这个太难了
Nicous: I can't play this, it's too hard.
Shure:  哎操
Shure: Oh, damn.
Shure:  他真的是c音吗
Shure: Is it really a C note?
Nicous:  夹四频
Nicous: Capo on the fourth fret.
Shure: 夹四频啊
Shure: Capo on the fourth fret, huh.
Shure: 慢点慢点
Shure: Slower, slower.
Shure:  哒哒哒
Shure: Da da da.
Shure:  你从留着长长
Shure: You start with the long...
Nicous:  要不换一个吧
Nicous: How about we switch to another one?
Nicous:  感觉有点难
Nicous: This feels a bit hard.
Nicous:  哈哈对了
Nicous: Haha, right.
Nicous:  我看出来了
Nicous: I figured it out.
Nicous:  哎他这两个人还得互相切
Nicous: Hey, they still need to cut each other off.
Katrina:  对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Nicous: 放开
Nicous: Let go.
Shure:  我其实你再看两遍我能
Shure: Actually, if you watch it two more times, I can...
Shure:  就是你俩根本不会唱是是
Shure: You two basically can't sing, right?
Shure:  太太
Shure: Too much.
Shure:  来来男孩吧
Shure: Come on, boys.
Nicous: 想你的夜晚
Nicous: Missing you at night.
Shure:  修硕唱的最痛的一首歌吗
Shure: Is this the song that hurts the most for me to sing?
Nicous: 来吧
Nicous: Go ahead.
Nicous: 这我肯定能唱
Nicous: I can definitely sing this.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  你找对调了吗
Shure: Did you find the right tune?
Nicous: 啊第一个地的后面全错了
Nicous: Ah, everything after the first note was wrong.
Shure:  哥
Shure: Bro.
Shure:  这我肯定能唱
Shure: I can definitely sing this.
Nicous: 你弹的不对呵呵
Nicous: You're playing it wrong, haha.
Nicous: 我肯定可以来 我在开始
Nicous: I can definitely do it. I'll start.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  啊分分手那天
Shure: Ah, the day we broke up...
Shure:  你看
Shure: Look.
Shure:  我是不是可以接着把它默写下去
Shure: Can I continue to write it down from memory?
Nicous: 还有什么歌
Nicous: What other songs are there?
Katrina: 流沙会吧
Katrina: How about "Quicksand"?
Nicous: 流沙也太难了吧
Nicous: "Quicksand" is too hard.
Nicous: 这个
Nicous: This one.
Katrina: 这什么 啊可以
Katrina: What's this? Ah, okay.
Shure: 是怎么这个遇到没
Shure: Did you encounter this?
Shure:  啊啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah, ah.
Shure:  哒哒哒哒
Shure: Da da da da.
Shure: 好 我知道
Shure: Okay, I got it.
Tasha:我不是在
Tasha: I'm not...
Shure:  好不好
Shure: Is it good?
Shure:  韩子丹好不好
Shure: How about Han Zidan?
Katrina: 草这首
Katrina: Crap, this song...
Shure:  你有没有发现你爸把下面这狗挡住了
Shure: Did you notice your dad blocked the dog below?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  从哪给给老板表演一下
Shure: Let's perform for the boss.
Jake:嗯来验收
Jake: Hmm, let's see.
Shure:  太阳公公出来聊吧好吧
Shure: Mr. Sun, come out and chat, okay?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Shure:  唱啊倒是
Shure: Sing, come on
Katrina:  哈哈哈你拍一下子
Katrina: Hahaha, you clap
Shure:  我太爱太爱
Shure: I love, love it
Shure:  我找不到
Shure: I can't find it
Shure:  喂你好
Shure: Hello, hi
Shure:  你好
Shure: Hello
Shure:  只能克服
Shure: We can only overcome it
Shure:  可以很棒很棒
Shure: It can be really great
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Yes, yes
Katrina:  直接弹吉他了
Katrina: Let's just play the guitar
Katrina:  感觉跳舞感觉有点难
Katrina: Dancing feels a bit tough
Katrina:  哈哈合唱可以
Katrina: Hahaha, chorus is fine
Katrina:  还不要还不要预算吧
Katrina: And we don't need a budget, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Right
Nicous: 把那个把那个预算把那个预算给我把钢琴
Nicous: Give me the budget, the budget for the piano
Jake: 应该还没有
Jake: We probably don't have it yet
Nicous: 打个车过来就行
Nicous: Just take a cab over
Jake: 可以啊可以
Jake: Sure, sure
Katrina: 你是什么电钢琴
Katrina: What kind of electric piano do you have?
Nicous: 电钢琴
Nicous: Electric piano
Jake: 整个乐队
Jake: The whole band
Jake: 可以啊挺好
Jake: Sure, sounds good
Nicous: 不用拆那个好方便
Nicous: No need to dismantle, it's convenient
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed
Katrina: 让大家处于一种沉寂的状态
Katrina: Let everyone be in a quiet state
Shure:  我们还刚刚即兴创作了一首歌
Shure: We just improvised a song
Katrina: 草履虫变异
Katrina: Paramecium mutation
Jake: 来请
Jake: Come on, please
Nicous: 我把我把电钢拿过来看能不能
Nicous: I'll bring the electric piano and see if it works
Jake: 哦好啊
Jake: Oh, sure
Jake: 这是开情歌了
Jake: This is starting a love song
Jake: 是开始了吗
Jake: Is it starting?
Shure:  完了唱太多别的
Shure: Done, sang too much other stuff
Shure:  我把我刚才自己
Shure: I just
Shure:  你们给我放一遍
Shure: Play it for me once
Shure:  我刚才那个我草
Shure: I just, damn
Shure:  我是一只草履虫啊
Shure: I'm a paramecium
Shure:  OK OK
Shure: OK, OK
Shure:  可以了不过他还在这呢
Shure: It's fine, but he's still here
Shure:  笑哈哈呵呵呵呵
Shure: Hahaha hehehe
Katrina: 好决定了到时候你上台
Katrina: Okay, it's decided, you'll go on stage then.
Jake:比那个苏罗要强
Jake: Better than that Sulo.
Shure:  哈哈是吧
Shure: Haha, right?
Jake: 比苏罗
Jake: Better than Sulo.
Shure:  苏罗就是AI
Shure: Sulo is just an AI.
Shure:  他就会给你奇奇怪怪
Shure: It only gives you weird stuff.
Jake: 我给你我给你放一个苏罗AI
Jake: Let me show you a Sulo AI.
Katrina: ok那叫乐队
Katrina: Okay, let's call it a band.
Jake: 好啊好啊
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jake: 那我练练
Jake: I'll practice then.
Jake: 要不伴个舞吧你就
Jake: How about you dance along?
Katrina: 哎我朋友也有吉它
Katrina: Hey, my friend also has a guitar.
Jake: 哈哈哈伴个舞吧要
Jake: Hahaha, dance along, yeah.
Katrina: 我们可以确定一下曲
Katrina: We can decide on the song.
Katrina: 感觉唱歌比较好弹
Katrina: Singing feels easier to play.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  我们可以唱心造的人
Shure: We can sing "Heart-Made Man."
Shure:  哈哈哈可以啊
Shure: Hahaha, sure.
Jake: 你在这迎宾
Jake: You greet the guests here.
Shure:  可以吧你看这种就是旋律很洗脑
Shure: Sounds good, you see, this melody is so catchy.
Shure:  是
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  我就会写这种洗脑烂俗小歌你知道吧
Shure: I just write these catchy, cheesy little songs, you know?
Shure:  对你可以这样截着哦
Shure: Yeah, you can cut it like this.
Shure:  我是一只超级虫
Shure: I am a super bug.
Shure:  哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒
Shure: Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da
Shure:  哒哒哒哒
Shure: Da-da-da-da
Katrina: 鉴定一下题目吧
Katrina: Let's decide on the title.
Shure:  草履虫之歌
Shure: Song of the Paramecium.
Shure:  是的你编批
Shure: Yes, you arrange it.
Shure:  你回去一测
Shure: You test it when you get back.
Shure:  是
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 觉得这个更有意思了是
Shure: I think this is more interesting.
Nicous:  完了
Nicous: Done.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Nicous:  老板
Nicous: Boss.
Jake:给一个style
Jake: Give me a style.
Jake: 给一个music style heavy metal
Jake: Give me a music style, heavy metal.
Shure:  happy metal
Shure: Happy metal.
Shure: 它生成的happy metal都非常的抽象的
Shure: The happy metal it generates is really abstract.
Jake: 哦真的吗
Jake: Oh really?
Jake: 真的好嘞
Jake: Really, okay.
Shure:  之前那个让我们荡起双桨重金属
Shure: That metal version of "Let's Paddle Together" we did before...
Shure:  这真的是happy metal吗
Shure: Is this really happy metal?
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake: 这是pop他们不认识pop
Jake: This is pop. They don't recognize pop.
Jake: 这对味了
Jake: This hits the spot.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Jake: 哇他有歌词吗
Jake: Wow, does it have lyrics?
Jake: 等一下
Jake: Wait a minute.
Jake: 这是不是要
Jake: Is this supposed to...
Jake: 我把电脑搬出来了
Jake: I brought the computer out.
Jake: 呵呵呵这手机好像他不出歌词
Jake: Haha, this phone doesn't seem to show the lyrics.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn.
Shure:  你们在做狗
Shure: Are you guys making dog?
Shure:  很棒
Shure: Nice.
Shure:  有点东西只能说
Shure: There's something about this, I gotta say.
Shure:  我靠好香啊
Shure: Damn, it smells so good.
Shure:  还有烤地瓜
Shure: And roasted sweet potatoes.
Tasha: 烤了你吃吗
Tasha: If it's roasted, would you eat it?
Shure:  我草
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 我烤地瓜
Shure: I'll roast sweet potatoes.
Jake: 繁荣这经济繁荣
Jake: Prosperity, this economic prosperity.
Jake: 局部经济繁荣
Jake: Regional economic prosperity.
Shure:  烤糊了
Shure: It's burnt.
Tasha: 我刚刚感觉不够熟
Tasha: I just thought it wasn't cooked enough.
Tasha: 又烤了一会
Tasha: So I roasted it a bit more.
Tasha: 你要不拿出去吃
Tasha: Do you want to take it outside to eat?
Shure:  我都看着好香
Shure: It smells so good, just looking at it.
Shure:  虽然我平时不吃烤地瓜
Shure: Even though I don't usually eat roasted sweet potatoes.
Shure:  但是饿了你知道吗
Shure: But I'm hungry, you know?
Shure:  呼呼呼哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  来张纸来张纸
Shure: Give me a napkin, give me a napkin.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn.
Tasha: 这个这个盒子放上面了
Tasha: Put this box on top.
Shure:  卧槽好他妈香啊
Shure: Whoa, it smells so damn good.
Shure:  好香啊我靠
Shure: It smells so good, damn.
Shure:  这皮他是不能吃
Shure: You can't eat the skin.
Shure:  他酥了
Shure: It's crispy.
Shure:  我说这皮都能吃
Shure: I mean, you can eat the skin.
Shure:  感觉
Shure: Feels
Tasha: 是啊煮过了
Tasha: Yeah, it's cooked.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn!
Jake:绝香
Jake: Absolutely fragrant.
Shure: 巨香
Shure: Super fragrant.
Shure:  我第一次
Shure: My first time...
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 干
Jake: Cheers.
Shure: 干一个
Shure: Cheers to that.
Shure:  干地瓜
Shure: Cheers to sweet potatoes.
Jake: 地瓜会自动翻译
Jake: Sweet potatoes will translate automatically.
Shure:  直接给我翻译成什么
Shure: Translate it to what?
Jake:：groundmelon
Jake: Groundmelon.
Shure:  对哈哈哈
Shure: Right, hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 来重金属摇滚
Jake: Let's go for heavy metal.
Shure: 好
Shure: Sure.
Jake:这不对呀这不对呀
Jake: This isn't right, this isn't right.
Jake: 是不是听不懂中文啊
Jake: Can't understand Chinese?
Jake: 哇只会pop吧
Jake: Wow, only knows pop?
Shure:  好pop呀
Shure: So pop.
Shure:  no style more her heavy metal
Shure: No style, more of her heavy metal.
Jake: 谢彬竹玩嗨了
Jake: Xie Binzhu is having a blast.
Jake: 第一回玩吗
Jake: First time playing?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 大家弹过钢琴
Jake: Everyone has played the piano.
Shure:  啊弹钢琴还不错
Shure: Ah, playing the piano isn't bad.
Shure:  我靠还给他化妆
Shure: Damn, even put on makeup.
Jake: 是是挺是挺可爱哎呦
Jake: Yes, yes, pretty cute, oh my.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 我专门睁大眼睛
Jake: I purposely opened my eyes wide.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 因为不好不好打草稿
Lucia: Because it's hard to draft.
Jake: 还有大眼睛
Jake: And big eyes.
Jake: 噢
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 所以就使用那个表情
Lucia: So just use that expression.
Lucia: 表情包模式
Lucia: Emoji mode.
Jake: 他不会
Jake: He can't.
Jake: 你得给他歌词
Jake: You need to give him the lyrics.
Tasha: 杨老师最需要你的时候来了
Tasha: Teacher Yang needs you the most right now.
Shure:  他们说有可能是
Shure: They said it might be.
Shure:  这是一个引子啊
Shure: This is a lead.
Shure:  有可能是个引子哦
Shure: It could be a lead.
Jake: 一个引子
Jake: A lead.
Shure:  让AI写我是草履虫和我
Shure: Let AI write "I am a paramecium and me."
Jake: 就是大伙可以给词他他词写的不行
Jake: So everyone can give words, but the words he writes are not good.
Jake: 如果觉得你觉得怎么样
Jake: What do you think?
Shure:  还行
Shure: Not bad.
Jake:确实还行
Jake: Indeed, not bad.
Shure:  很含糊哇哈哈哈这个节奏
Shure: Very vague, hahaha, this rhythm.
Jake: 哈哈哈完了
Jake: Hahaha, it's over.
Jake: 人机大战
Jake: Man vs. Machine.
Shure: 我败下一程居然
Shure: I actually lost a round.
Alice: 第一
Alice: First.
Tasha:第一
Tasha: First.
Shure: 巨好吃
Shure: Very delicious.
Jake: 啊我要搅和吗
Jake: Ah, should I mix it?
Tasha: 把它们揉在一起
Tasha: Mix them together.
Shure:  完了我输给AI了我靠
Shure: It's over, I lost to AI, damn.
Shure:  确实
Shure: Indeed.
Jake:哈哈哈但是没有记忆点
Jake: Hahaha, but there's no memorable point.
Jake: 我觉得对
Jake: I think so too.
Nicous: 我草AI和这个味道种一样
Nicous: Damn, AI and this taste are the same.
Shure:  这就非常草东味你知道吗
Shure: This is very Caodong style, you know?
Shure: 就是那个中间那个嘣嘣嘣嘣
Shure: Just that middle part, boom boom boom.
Shure:  你可以拿这个
Shure: You can use this.
Shure:  我刚刚那个纸杯
Shure: The paper cup I just had.
Shure:  拿它这么挤的
Shure: Squeeze it like this.
Alice:我都走路上了吗
Alice: Am I on the road?
Tasha: 吃吗
Tasha: Want to eat?
Shure: 我不玩了
Shure: I'm done playing.
Tasha:最后一个
Tasha: Last one.
Nicous: 我吃一半
Nicous: I'll eat half.
Shure:  对这个间奏还不错
Shure: Yes, this interlude is pretty good.
Jake: 没关系拿过来直接用
Jake: It's okay, just use it directly.
Shure:  这才是happy metal
Shure: This is true happy metal.
Shure:  但这这没词
Shure: But there's no lyrics.
Jake: 没词
Jake: No lyrics.
Shure:  这确实是happy make
Shure: This is indeed happy metal.
Jake: 他这写词很沙雕的
Jake: His lyrics are really silly.
Jake: 我看一下他是是没空间了还是什么
Jake: Let me check if he's out of space or something.
Alice: 应该录了有快3个小时了
Alice: We've probably been recording for almost 3 hours.
Alice: 我做小狗之前还有40多个G
Alice: Before I did the puppy thing, I had over 40GB left.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Shure: 哎呀我操
Shure: Oh my gosh!
Jake: 把那个他的Wei page直接copy过来
Jake: Just copy his Wei page directly over.
Jake: 就给写了一个
Jake: Just write one for him.
Shure:  这个才对
Shure: This is the correct way.
Shure:  你刚刚旺仔中间加个分号了
Shure: You added a semicolon in the middle of Wangzai.
Shure:  加个分号才才能
Shure: Adding a semicolon helps.
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, okay.
Shure:  就是识别下一个
Shure: It helps to identify the next one.
Jake: 笑什么
Jake: What's so funny?
Jake: 我也江苏人
Jake: I'm from Jiangsu too.
Jake: 但是我是很我
Jake: But I was very...
Jake: 我那时候还是病题作文
Jake: I had to write thematic essays back then.
Katrina: 你选的什么
Katrina: What did you choose?
Jake: 我我那时候还命题作文
Jake: I had to write thematic essays back then.
Katrina: 我知道 你选的什么科
Katrina: I know. What subjects did you choose?
Shure:  他没有
Shure: He didn't.
Shure:  没有
Shure: No subjects.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Shure:  哦你们只选两科
Shure: Oh, you guys only picked two subjects.
Jake: 对当初就是我
Jake: Yeah, back then, I...
Katrina: 我我
Katrina: I, I...
Katrina: 我不挑我生生我生物当时
Katrina: I didn't choose, I took Biology back then.
Katrina: 五个选择题四四个不确定那个定哪一家
Katrina: Four out of five multiple-choice questions, I wasn't sure which one to choose.
Katrina: 当时她昨文是什么就是
Katrina: Back then, what was her essay about...
Katrina: 嗯你觉得晚上就是我们一般
Katrina: You know, we usually...
Katrina: 批判信息减防啊然后它就问
Katrina: Criticize information reduction, and then they asked...
Shure:  啊
Shure: Uh-huh.
Katrina: 如果你一直看他一直给你推这个
Katrina: If you keep watching, they keep pushing this to you.
Katrina: 但是他那个很明显就是这个
Katrina: But it's obvious that...
Katrina: 出题人是支持这个现象的
Katrina: The person who made the questions supports this phenomenon.
Katrina: 但是大家可以通过这种推荐的
Katrina: But people can see through this kind of recommendation.
Shure:  我爱理工
Shure: I love engineering.
Shure:  我奔着北邮来的
Shure: I aimed for BUPT (Beijing University of Posts and Telecommunications).
Shure:  闹呢
Shure: Just kidding.
Shure:  我钱夹里当时放了两张照片
Shure: I had two photos in my wallet back then.
Shure:  一张老番茄一张何同学
Shure: One picture of Laofanqie, one picture of Hetongxue.
Shure:  差太多了
Shure: Such a big difference.
Shure:  人家他妈是复旦
Shure: He's from Fudan University.
Katrina: 你们那个北邮分是不是比985高
Katrina: Is your Beiyou score higher than the 985 schools?
Shure:  比比好多985分高
Shure: It's much higher than many 985 schools.
Shure:  我
Shure: I...
Shure:  不后悔
Shure: I don't regret it.
Shure:  我无所谓
Shure: I don't care.
Tasha: 套盒误差
Tasha: The set has a margin of error.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Jake: 能录吧这个啊
Jake: Can you record this?
Jake: 能录吧哈哈哈
Jake: Can you record this? Hahaha.
Jake: 没有
Jake: No.
Jake: 这一下午都没有
Jake: Nothing this whole afternoon.
Jake: 应该是不知道为什么可能是崩掉了
Jake: Probably don't know why, maybe it crashed.
Shure:  奖金
Shure: The bonus.
Jake: 来来写一首特朗普之歌
Jake: Come on, let's write a song about Trump.
Shure:  别别别
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure:  哎我们来命题作文battle吧
Shure: Hey, let's do a themed essay battle.
Shure:  大家随便出个题
Shure: Everyone just throw out a topic.
Shure:  然后让他写和让我写
Shure: Then let him write and I'll write.
Shure:  看看哪个更牛逼
Shure: Let's see which one is better.
Jake: 那出个题
Jake: Then give a topic.
Shure:  来出个题
Shure: Come on, give a topic.
Shure:  就随便说
Shure: Just say anything.
Jake:谢彬竹之歌吧
Jake: A song about Xie Binzhu.
Jake: 要不就哈哈哈
Jake: Or, hahaha.
Shure:  他不AI不知道谢彬竹是什么东西
Shure: He doesn't know what Xie Binzhu is.
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake: 我也给他形容一下
Jake: I'll describe it to him.
Jake: 谢彬竹是一个什么什么什么啊
Jake: Xie Binzhu is something, something, something.
Nicous: 谢彬竹是一个被吃掉会主动说谢谢的人
Nicous: Xie Binzhu is someone who will say thank you when eaten.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha.
Shure:  随便拿个什么物品之类的当命题
Shure: Just take any item as the topic.
Shure:  可以吧
Shure: Is that okay?
Jake:北冰洋吧
Jake: Beibingyang.
Shure:  北冰洋
Shure: Beibingyang.
Jake: 北冰洋
Jake: Beibingyang.
Jake: 北冰洋的什么
Jake: Beibingyang's what?
Jake: 唇唇膏
Jake: Lip balm.
Shure:  北冰洋的熊猫是吗
Shure: A panda in the Arctic Ocean, right?
Jake: 北冰洋的熊猫
Jake: A panda in the Arctic Ocean.
Jake: DK音乐
Jake: DK music.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 北冰洋的熊猫是吗
Shure: A panda in the Arctic Ocean, right?
Jake: style
Jake: Style.
Shure: style你随便
Shure: Style, whatever you like.
Jake:我我随便
Jake: Whatever I like.
Jake: 哦我靠
Jake: Oh damn.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 喂
Jake: Hello.
Jake: 喂哎呦我去啊
Jake: Hello, oh my god.
Jake: 你好呵呵你好你好
Jake: Hi, haha, hi, hi.
Jake: 来了来了来了来了
Jake: Here we go, here we go, here we go.
Shure:  哎帮帮把把把着一下扶一下
Shure: Hey, help me hold this, support it a bit.
Jake: 帮我帮我敲敲吧啊
Jake: Help me knock it, yeah?
Shure:  你别让他happy metal就泡吧就好了
Shure: Just don’t let it turn into happy metal, just mix it up.
Shure:  你或者你不指定style你直接就是
Shure: Or you don’t specify the style, just...
Jake: hello hello哎哎哎你在哪啊
Jake: Hello, hello, hey, hey, hey, where are you?
Shure:  不用他他会自动也也也生成一个style
Shure: No need, it will automatically generate a style.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 套装误拆
Lucia: Outfit mistake.
Lucia: 我还给他剪了个尾巴
Lucia: I even cut him a tail.
Shure:  他
Shure: He...
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 要不走上去
Jake: How about going up?
Jake: 帮我拿一下吧
Jake: Help me get it, please.
Jake: 来谢谢你啊
Jake: Thank you.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure:  不行
Shure: No.
Shure:  北冰洋的熊猫
Shure: A panda in the Arctic Ocean.
Jake: 有词吗在这是吧
Jake: Are there lyrics? Here, right?
Jake: 不是这个
Jake: Not this one.
Jake: 我我以前喜欢给他写的
Jake: I used to like writing for him.
Jake: 就是直接给他style OP
Jake: Just give him the style OP.
Jake: 对就是animation OP啊
Jake: Yeah, the animation OP.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 就是
Jake: Just...
Jake: 就感觉北朝与战士的那种那种东西
Jake: It feels like that Northern Warrior kind of thing.
Jake: 永不什么
Jake: Never what...
Shure:  永不窒息
Shure: Never suffocate.
Jake: 永不窒息
Jake: Never suffocate.
Jake: 嗯他默认应该都是流星
Jake: Hmm, he usually defaults to a shooting star.
Shure:  我不能受他牵连
Shure: I can't get involved with him.
Shure:  我要构思我自己
Shure: I need to think for myself.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 上吧
Jake: Go for it.
Jake: 走上去饭
Jake: Let's go eat.
Shure:  吃饭
Shure: Let's eat.
Jake: 上去配个乐吧要不就
Jake: How about adding some music?
Jake: 饭店驻唱
Jake: Restaurant singer.
Jake: 哈哈哈那李先生
Jake: Hahaha, then Mr. Li...
Shure:  那我是不是得
Shure: Then should I...
Jake: 李先生面馆
Jake: Mr. Li's noodle shop.
Shure: 前面得给我立个二维码
Shure: There should be a QR code in front.
Shure:  好吧哈哈哈
Shure: Okay, hahaha.
Jake: 李先生面馆驻唱
Jake: Mr. Li's noodle shop singer.
Jake: 首席驻唱
Jake: Lead singer.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  别抬了抬了还需好费劲的
Shure: Don't lift it, it's a lot of effort.
Shure:  这个反正是一人一份
Shure: Anyway, everyone gets one portion.
Shure:  这种有个座吃就行
Shure: As long as there's a seat, it's fine.
Jake: 哎对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake: 蹲着吃都行
Jake: Even squatting is fine.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  赶早好吧
Shure: Better to be early.
Shure:  开始黑武汉人了
Shure: Starting to bash Wuhan people. 种族宗教问题
Nicous: 哦靠这什么东西啊
Nicous: Oh man, what is this?
Shure:  对套餐里的小菜
Shure: The side dishes in the set meal.
Nicous: 这么钓啊
Nicous: So fancy.
Shure:  谁的番茄面
Shure: Whose tomato noodles?
Lucia: 我的
Lucia: Mine.
Shure:  好哦
Shure: Okay.
Lucia:好哦
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha: 番茄面应该不要米饭
Tasha: Tomato noodles shouldn't come with rice.
Shure:  还有安格斯肥牛面
Shure: And Angus beef noodles.
Shure:  招牌牛肉面
Shure: Signature beef noodles.
Shure:  对我的没错
Shure: Yep, that's mine.
Nicous: 三个吧
Nicous: Three, right?
Katrina: 这是谁的梅饼
Katrina: Whose plum cakes are these?
Shure: 这是
Jake:这我的
Shure:  每人三个
Shure:  这个是吗
Shure:  我不知道反正是咚不咚
Shure:  咚不咚咚咚
Jake: 我操哈哈哈
Shure:  臭二次元滚出去
Jake: 哼这不行了
Jake: 来一个
Jake: 考虑啊你
Shure:  你是不是私宅
Shure:  真恶心啊
Shure:  让人坐不下
Tasha: 那我是什么
Shure:  要不我坐小孩那桌去吧
Tasha:我是
Nicous: 我跟你一起吧
Tasha: 海带丝和
Shure: 老板
Shure:  北冰洋
Shure: Arctic Ocean
Shure:  北冰洋的熊猫
Shure: Panda of the Arctic Ocean
Shure:  要加点香菜吗
Shure: Should we add some cilantro?
Lucia: 其实我可以加
Lucia: Actually, I can add some.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:他是不是没给米饭
Alice: Did he forget the rice?
Shure:  这一生吃的最多的面
Shure: The noodles I've eaten the most in my life
Shure:  就是李先生牛肉面
Shure: are Mr. Lee's beef noodles.
Shure:  你呢
Shure: What about you?
Lucia:他还在很认真的唱这首歌
Lucia: He's still seriously singing this song.
Shure: 他妈的我是要吃饭
Shure: Damn, I want to eat.
Shure: 你等我吃饭完
Shure: Wait for me to finish eating.
Shure:  构思一下的
Shure: I'll think about it.
Jake:他写的陶喆曲风
Jake: He wrote in David Tao's style.
Jake:来评一评
Jake: Let's review it.
Shure:  这
Shure: This
Shure:  这确实有点陶喆那味味
Shure: This really does have a bit of David Tao's flavor.
Katrina: 太抽像了
Katrina: Too abstract.
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha
Jake:还有料吗
Jake: Got any more?
Jake: 我应该我应该搞什么呀
Jake: What should I do?
Nicous: 搞一个
Nicous: Do one.
Shure: 不不不
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure:  把这个端拿起来
Shure: Pick up this end.
Shure:  然后把它倒到那个下面汤里面
Shure: And then pour it into the soup underneath.
Jake: 我靠这外卖这讲究
Jake: Wow, this takeout is fancy.
Shure:  帮帮你弄进去
Shure: Let me help you put it in.
Shure:  这可是走出国门的面
Shure: This is noodles that have gone international.
Shure:  这是开到美美国加州的牛肉面
Shure: These are beef noodles that made it to California, USA.
Alice: 谁的鸡没拿
Alice: Who didn't take their chicken?
Jake:还有鸡
Jake: There's chicken too?
Shure:  我的鸡
Shure: My chicken.
Alice:谁的鸡
Alice: Whose chicken?
Shure:  这是我点的鸡吗
Shure: Is this the chicken I ordered?
Shure:  拿个垫直接坐地下就好
Shure: Just get a mat and sit on the floor.
Shure:  完了没垫
Shure: Oh no, no mat.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  卧槽哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Whoa, hahaha.
Jake: 这个应该过去
Jake: This should go there.
Lucia: 啊我撒了一个
Lucia: Ah, I spilled one.
Alice: 这有葱和香菜
Alice: There's green onions and cilantro here.
Alice: 有人要吗
Alice: Does anyone want it?
Shure:  我加了
Shure: I added some.
Alice: 还有好几包呢
Alice: There are several more packs.
Alice: 那边要吗
Alice: Does anyone over there want it?
Shure:  嗯拆出来不知道
Shure: Hmm, I don't know after opening it.
Jake: 来个李师傅牛肉面吧
Jake: Let's get a Master Li's beef noodle.
Shure:  李先生
Shure: Mr. Li.
Shure:  周杰伦的风格
Shure: Jay Chou's style.
Jake:周杰伦的风格
Jake: Jay Chou's style.
Jake: 不好周杰伦这个是敏感词
Jake: No good, Jay Chou is a sensitive word. 社会问题
Jake: 不行这感觉太贵了
Jake: No way, this feels too expensive.
Jake: 陶喆不够贵
Jake: David Tao isn't expensive enough.
Nicous: 贼臭贼臭
Nicous: Super smelly, super smelly.
Shure:  贼臭贼臭
Shure: Super smelly, super smelly.
Shure:  好这个行了吧
Shure: Alright, this should be fine, right?
Jake:这行这行
Jake: This is fine, this is fine.
Jake:牛肉面里几块牛肉
Jake: How many pieces of beef are in the beef noodles?
Shure:  你放心一只手肯定能数过来
Shure: Don't worry, you can definitely count them on one hand.
Shure:  这他妈叫周杰伦
Shure: This is called Jay Chou. 社会问题
Jake:他这里写个男的
Jake: It says here it's a guy.
Shure:  哈哈哈怎么任性
Shure: Hahaha, how capricious.
Shure:  包括这个
Shure: Including this one.
Shure:  那时候还有什么网络歌曲
Shure: What other internet songs were there back then?
Shure:  伤不起
Shure: "Can't Take It".
Nicous: 爱情不是你想买就能
Nicous: Love isn't something you can just buy...
Shure:  现在又要用真爱
Shure: Now you have to use true love.
Lucia: 你说眼镜吗
Lucia: Are you talking about glasses?
Lucia: 他现在没有灯亮着
Lucia: There's no light on now.
Lucia: 我现在能按长按这个电脑
Lucia: I can press and hold this computer now.
Jake:插充电宝了没有
Jake: Did you plug in the power bank?
Lucia:插了
Lucia: Plugged in.
Jake:那插了充电宝有用吗
Jake: So, does plugging in the power bank work?
Lucia: 会充电宝没电了
Lucia: The power bank is out of battery.
Katrina:  充电宝没电了
Katrina: The power bank is out of battery.
Lucia:充电宝没电了
Lucia: The power bank is out of battery.
Lucia: 你找到了
Lucia: You found it.
手机声音：我的漂亮杯子
Phone Voice: My beautiful cup.
手机声音：到了然后我刚刚去京东快递
Phone Voice: It arrived, and I just went to JD Express.
手机声音：然后回来路上在嗯瑞幸门口
Phone Voice: Then on the way back, at the entrance of Luckin.
手机声音：瑞幸对面
Phone Voice: Opposite Luckin.
手机声音：然后碰到一个关系特别好的一个学弟
Phone Voice: I ran into a junior who I'm really close with.
手机声音：他牵着他女朋友站在那里
Phone Voice: He was standing there holding his girlfriend's hand.
手机声音：就是就是站在那里等我走过去
Phone Voice: Just standing there waiting for me to walk past.
手机声音：然后跟我说晚上好
Phone Voice: Then he said good evening to me.
手机声音：我在那玩手机呢
Phone Voice: I was just playing with my phone there.
手机声音：然后一抬头靠两个人
Phone Voice: I looked up and there were two people.
手机声音：就因为一第一眼看到是那个姑娘
Phone Voice: Because the first person I saw was the girl.
手机声音：我是不认识的
Phone Voice: I didn't recognize her.
手机声音：然后他跟我说晚上好
Phone Voice: Then he said good evening to me.
手机声音：我愣了一下
Phone Voice: I was a bit stunned.
手机声音：就本来没认出来
Phone Voice: I didn't recognize him at first.
手机声音：听声音我才反应过来是谁
Phone Voice: I recognized him by his voice.
手机声音：他两次用的箱子不一样哎
Phone Voice: He used a different box twice.
手机声音：这个上面还给贴了标签
Phone Voice: This one even has a label on it.
手机声音： 我希望这个
Phone Voice: I hope this one...
手机声音：他不要再有那种奇怪的瑕疵
Phone Voice: doesn't have any weird defects again.
手机声音：不然我真的很崩溃
Phone Voice: Otherwise, I'll be really frustrated.